[Musique]
j'accroche pas
mais à personne
si vous pensiez avoir tout vu cet
internaute a déniché la première école
d'influenceurs française il y a des
devoir l'objectif pour chaque élève et
de tenir à mes followers instagram est
de générer plus de 5000 euros par mois
non si on a la neige ne s'est pas que
chez vous et
c'est pas possible impossible de mener
un train de vie pareille avec seulement
vingt mille abonnés fait-on remarquer en
ligne ou ce clip de promotion amusé
voire inquiète tant il paraît suspect
yoth champagne et jet privé contre une
formation visio à 1200 euros tr s en est
votre avis mieux vaut éviter de cliquer
en cinq ans de pouvoir macron et de sa
majorité la fortune des 500 plus riche
de france est passée de 570 milliards à
1000 milliards c'est quasiment doublé la
fortune des français à ce que je sache
n'a pas doublé ni les pensions de
retraite ni les salaires
bout de la mer a été un tout petit peu
plus précis quoique regardons ensemble
ce que dynamiser l'économie il faudra à
partir du 1er janvier que sur
l'électricité et le gaz il y ait des
augmentations pour ceux qui peuvent se
le permettre on tiendra compte du niveau
de revenu mieux le chiffre 13 une crise
d'angoissé c'est tout simple tu parles
de tes doigts de pierre
tu les contractures moment que la
fraction jusqu'au mans lyon contre les
abdos et but du jeu c'est d'arriver
jusqu'en haut du corps
mon gars le plus longtemps
et par ailleurs il ya un autre point
alors il ya un son qui arrivent de nulle
part ailleurs la voix
arrive dans les grandes gueules alors
est-ce qu'on peut arrêter leçon s'il
vous plaît
ça sert à ça c'est la première fois que
ça nous arrive ça pardon et bruce qui a
demandé que sa voix nous à l'entente
mais nous on peut passer héros en
gironde où on l'entend pas parce que
vous avez pas le nom là l'euro ni
le studio on a un retour sur le pré que
plusieurs fois par des mtv nous sommes
en 2015 en pleine fronde des taxis
contre les chauffeur vtc à cette époque
hubert est attaqué de toutes parts en
france mais dispose d'un allié de poids
au sein du gouvernement
emmanuel macron alors ministre de
l'économie entretient d'étroites
relations avec l'entreprise américaine
depuis plusieurs mois c'est ce que
révèle l enquête uber file du consortium
international des journalistes
d'investigation
[Musique]
ils mettent en garde leurs rivaux en
vantant leur force et leur taille
le son résonne à plus d'un kilomètre à
la ronde
ils veulent décourager leurs concurrents
ce mail par exemple a été rédigé par un
lobbyiste du beurre à ses collaborateurs
après une première rencontre au
ministère spectaculaire du jamais vu on
quitte bercy et on file à l'aéroport je
vous tapez un rapport dans la journée
beaucoup de boulot à venir mais on va
danser bientôt cette espèce de en
examinant
découvrir la neige n'ont pas souvent
chez eux ouais
c'est désormais une tradition et
l'événement choose friends choisissez la
france en bon français se tient à
versailles aujourd'hui en présence du
président macro venus de 43 pays près de
200 chefs d'entreprise étrangers ont été
reçus en grande pompe l'elysée en mode
vrp pour la cinquième année consécutive
avant même le début de la rencontre des
investissements à hauteur de 6,7
milliards d'euros ont été annoncés parce
que je commence à en avoir ras-le-bol de
ce pays où on ne travaille plus et je
suis désolé mais met la sncf au rythme
estival au mois de juillet non les gens
qui à paris travaille à paris en région
parisienne au mois de juillet ils sont
au boulot mais quel est le prix à payer
pour attirer ces grands pas trop le
gouvernement est il obligé de promettre
aux multinationales une fiscalité
allégée ou un droit du travail
assouplies pour créer des emplois
faut-il sacrifier le droit des salariés
si vous voyez par exemple le soir il ya
des gens qui ramassent les poubelles
mais hier soir il n'avait de fait contre
un camion que l'ancien cavalier
d'entraînement chez les kids are qu'est
ce que je fais
et dont c'était tabou ce déjeuner au
dîner la cie déjeuner prenant parce que
ça fonctionne pas comme kiev avait
l'accord m'en cache une pause déjeuner
c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne
écoutez merci pour cet
américain est intéressé pour l'adapter
la série on ne manquera pas de donner
les coordonnées